okay uh we are going to be a little bit
dangerous we are going to cover for the
god butcher now here's the deal I did a
rundown episode on this what's before we
was like Thor versus Galactus and it was
really fun because that's what we get
you know it's actually the the later
part of the story I think it's the
second half I want to say it's God bomb
where we end up getting that but really
everything from like Thor god of thunder
number 1 all the way up to like number 9
or number 10 I think it might even be 12
like ever exactly how many issues off
top my head it's all one kind of one
cohesive story it's all just like one
great big story but for those of you
guys who are reading Jane Foster Thor
this is really where Jason Aaron's run
kicks off now Jane Foster won't be come
forward for quite some time we actually
focus almost exclusively on Odin's son
but here's the other funny thing - I've
already recorded the origin of gore the
god butcher and I'm probably going to
release that after this video comes out
so you guys are gonna watch this video
then watch the origin of poor and then
in the origin of gore I'm going to act
like this video hasn't been made it was
going to be kind of a weird scenario but
uh but the fact remains here that sort
of the god butcher is really one of the
greatest stories ever told when it comes
to the character of Thor I mean there's
that's just the way it is it is it's so
incredibly good because in my mind it
really reinvigorates and really
revitalize the store now once the movie
Ragnarok comes out will actually start
all the way back with Thor Ragnarok and
then get into a J michael Straczynski 's
run and then that fractions run which
basically covers everything leading up
to this particular story so it'll be
just one great big cohesive playlist
with something like 30 videos or 40
videos by the time we get done with it
but it will be pretty cool in terms of
how it all comes together that includes
like fear itself and the tie ends and
all that kind of stuff because fear
itself is really really good so we throw
the god butcher the great thing is that
we basically join up with three
different generations of Thor now the
way to Jason arrant doesn't it paces out
and it makes perfect sense when I was
going through it it wasn't convoluted it
wasn't difficult to understand not at
all because it tells one cohesive story
over three generations one part I guess
the part that we pick up with isn't 893
ad now back when it came to Thor in the
modern day his stories are pretty
straightforward
but really writers just kind of pick and
choose what they use from like the early
days of thoughts you can really just
kind of throw anything in there I mean
we've seen stories that have been kind
of thrown in with uncanny Avengers for
example or Thor fought apocalypse when
Thor was fighting apocalypse because of
the fact
the webinar had at the time because it
wasn't worthy to wield me on here yet
wield his hammer because of because was
actually armed was not powerful enough
to defeat apocalypse he in turn had to
act magically enchanted so that it could
defeat apocalypse and that was the
explanation going forward for why the
axe of Thor has a magical enchantment on
it why it's so much more powerful than
any other axe because it needed to be in
order to defeat apocalypse these are the
kind of things that writers use in order
to add things in there because for years
and years and years he act the one that
will see him using in this story it was
really just an action that was there
like it was just a weapon that he used
so we really didn't know the basis
behind it we didn't know why it was so
capable
it just was and so that story of uncanny
Avengers offered that explanation now
the cool thing is that Thor showing up
really in this town on the western coast
of Iceland is designed to show us that
there are a myriad of gods that exist
out there in the realm of Marvel Comics
now this is kind of a wholesale rework
by Jason Aaron um he's not like
rebooting the god mythology and Marvel
comics not at all he's actually adding
in new information and the reason why I
say that is because when it comes to
gods and Marvel there are gods and then
there are cosmic entities and they're
two distinctly different things cosmic
entities represent an aspect of the
universe so like you know eternity
represents time infinity reveries in
space The Living Tribunal is basically
the judge of the multiverse the one
above all created everything and then
from there you've got like master order
and Lord chaos master order represents
absolute order in the universe
Lord chaos represents absolute chaos in
the universe and they have to exist in
balance in order for the be chaos and
order and the in-betweener represents
that balance there are a lot of
different you know representations of
what the different entities mean but in
terms of gods you have the Greek gods of
Olympus you have the Asgardian gods of
North's mythology you have the sky
father's which are just kind of like
these head gods of all these different
religions that exist out there
judeo-christianity more or less Yahweh
you have Vishnu you have all these
different gods that exist out there but
for years that's really all there was it
was just modern Greek mythology and
modern Roman mythology which is just
kind of a reworking of Greek mythology
you had existing religions from around
the world and the gods represented in
comic books what Jason Aaron does is he
expands that and he says other planets
and other races have their own gods and
those gods are just as real as Thor and
so again it's really
kind of cool because it gives us this
perspective on how it all comes together
the issue with this if it's someone's
then traveling around and someone's been
killing them all now of course again
this takes place in the past and 893 AD
and so with someone running around and
killing all these gods
well then from there it's just a mission
of four to find out who that person is
now from here we jump to the present day
and we actually pick up on a place
called the planet in the GAR now the
planet in Dakar will be very very
similar to the planet that belongs to a
Tagore the God butcher and in fact this
was explicitly designed by Jason Aaron
himself to give us this kind of parallel
between how things could have been for
Gore and how things turned out to be for
Gore and of course we'll find more about
that in our video on on the origin of
the god butcher himself but the doctor
names here but this is really Thor just
kind of being depicted as a character
who very much hears the prayers of every
living being out there now this is also
kind of a new introduction for Jason
Aaron because Thor historically wasn't
really a god to like heard the prayers
of mortals I mean he would deal with
mortals he would fighting conflicts to
protect mortals different things like
that and it was more or less just like a
generally accepted thing that had
happened every once in a while but it
wasn't like it was a guaranteed in stone
yes Thor hears the prayers of all
mortals no matter where they are in the
universe
it wasn't like it is now but Jason Aaron
is throwing this in here in order to
give us a perspective of where Thor
stands in relation to all the other gods
telling us that God's everywhere hear
the prayers sometimes they'll answer
sometimes they won't it really just
depends on what that gods motivation are
you know what they what their motivation
is if they're a god of destruction they
will not answer the prayers of a society
if that's being destroyed but if they're
a god of life then they will answer the
prayers of a society that's being
destroyed because they exist to preserve
life so again what we end up doing is we
end up picking up with one of the
members of this of this you know race on
this planet who's basically saying look
we play to our gods and our gods never
answered well the belief of Thor and the
knowledge of Thor is that because there
are gods out there because the gods of
these planets would respond to their
denizens if they're not but it means
that the gods are derelict in their duty
or it means that something is wrong and
so what he does is he actually travels
to the realm of the Lords of ending are
the Lords or I guess the gods of this
particular planet only to find out that
they're all dead that they've all been
slaughtered somebody went through and
just killed every single one of them and
this is a huge thing because we're
talking about beings we don't know what
their power is but we can guarantee that
they have your like standard
the mill for abilities super strength
endurance longevity so on and so forth
and so for someone to walk into a
chamber of these things and kill them
off would be tantamount to somebody
walking into add guard and killing
everyone like definitely that just is
inconceivable we can't imagine of a
scenario where a singular being would
walk into Asgard and kill everyone shy
of someone who could just work reality
on a universal scale so again this is a
really crazy scenario but for here we
jump to several millennia into the
future to what's left of Asgard
effectively everybody in Asgard is gone
and the only person left is old King
Thor for those of you guys who are
reading or who have been reading Jane
Foster Thor one of the things you'll
notice about old King Thor is that his
arm is missing and in fact this is a
question that I've received time and
time again and I believe I had answered
it but I may not have in the inaugural
story when Jane Foster became for Jason
Erin basically wrote a circumstance
whereby Odin's son lost his own and he
basically used the destroyer armor as a
replacement on what does this point this
several millennia in the future this
takes place well after the events of the
modern day Thor and it seems like this
is basically the future version of the
Thor that were used to be lost his arm
but he is the sole survivor of Asgard we
don't know exactly what it is that
happened therefore at least at the
moment we don't it's actually explained
in a Loki agent of Asgard but we don't
know exactly what it is that happened
there all we know is that Asgard has
been completely overrun by these black
surfaces by forces of or the god butcher
and so again it presents a very bleak
future presents a very bleak outcome in
the sense that this is basically a
multi-generational fight you know in the
past 893 ad thorne encountered dog
butcher for the very first time in the
present day he's trying to track him
back down and in the future Gore appears
to have won and so it's a really cool
scenario because then what Jason Aaron
does for the rest of this story if he
connects the dots
he says if Thor met nil Gore for the
first time in the past and then he's
tracking him down again in the present
and seems to have lost in the future and
how do we get from A to B to C and it's
so cool to see it unfold it's so cool to
see it happen because what Thor does is
he continues his journey to basically
travel around you know back in the past
at 893 AD he continues his journey to
try to track down this person who has
basically killed these gods which of
course leads them into a direct
conflict with Gore the god butcher now
the important thing to notice here is
that again with this taking place in the
past
Thor's never faced anyone like this
before Thor's never faced anyone like
Gore Gore has this necro sword it
basically allows him to kill gods now it
is the source of its power but the real
benefit of the necro sword is that it is
a weapon of the gods and so it would be
like trying to fight Superman with a
steel sword versus trying to fight
Superman with a kryptonite sword one is
going to work and one is not the necro
sword basically allows Gore to kill gods
is the weapon for God to kill a god and
it was previously owned by gods of
course we'll learn more about that in
the origin of gore itself but the fact
remains here that with Thor facing off
against Korg this is a hit or two
unrivaled situation Thor's never dealt
with anything like this a person who
just cannot be stopped cannot be
reasoned with all he wants to do is just
kill Thor now the cool thing about this
is that Gore has like some amazing
dialogue in this story and that's really
one of the reasons why readers love him
so much is because he's got such amazing
dialogue you know he was like look you
know I fought so many gods I fought gods
of war are you a God of War because I
thought and I've killed so many of them
I thought gods of Wrath I fought all
these different gods and I've killed
them all you will be no different not
only that Thor of course charging into
battle you know for Asgard I'm Thor god
of thunder of Asgard what this does is
it turns Gore onto the idea that he can
basically begin the process of killing
even more gods by an invading Asgard so
again this is a really cool scenario
because what it does is it gives us this
conflict between two beings who have
never met before but who seem to be
virtually you know virtually equal in
power now horse jumping back to the to
the modern day this is really when Thor
begins to realize what it is that's
going on by going through this temple
you know this this this realm where
these gods were effectively been killed
he's been harkening back on his memories
of conflicting with with with gore and
this is when he realizes that he
previously believed he had killed Gort
only to find out that Gore is still very
much alive and so again this is
interesting because what it does is it
continues to sort of fill in the gaps it
continues to sort of let us know what's
going on of corresponding the gods of
this planet having been killed
Thor travels to a place called
omnipotence city now omnipotence city is
new Jason Aaron invented this this is a
place that never existed before and this
is
I say he's doing this wholesale
revamping of sorts when it comes to the
God mythology and Marvel Comics because
previously the only real meeting the
only real form of meeting among the gods
so to speak was the sky fathers that was
it you know the leaders of these various
godly Pantheon and that's really all
there was
but with omnipotent city what it does is
it basically creates a central hub of
information and within on Neptune City
is basically knowledge on everything
about everything now Thor is not looking
to learn everything that there is
instead this is Jason Aaron basically
saying this library is filled with like
the stories the achievements all these
different things of every God in
existence
and so what four begins to do is travel
around to every single realm where these
gods are supposed to exist to every
planet where these gods reside to every
moon the whole nine yards and all he
finds is dead God after dead God they
have all been butchered every last one
of them have been killed whether it's
these massive gods whether it's these
small gods what are their dreams you
know whether they're gods of destruction
gods of war it doesn't matter every
single one of them has been completely
destroyed and completely obliterated and
so having found that all these gods have
been completely obliterated what Thor
does is he reflects back on the final
battle that he had with Gore in the past
and recalls the cave the base of
operations so to speak death war where
I'm sorry that Gore was operating out of
and so traveling back to this location
where he intends to confront war again
he actually comes into contact for the
first time with a guy by the name of
Shadrach I think it is now this is kind
of cool because Shadrach is just like a
god of wine and it's really interesting
to see how like juice and Aaron is very
much invoking like this Greek
mythological godly pantheon and just
kind of applying it to Marvel and then
spreading it throughout the universe
those gods of wine as gods of dancing
there's gods of the harvest gods of the
hunt gods of the Sun so on and so forth
it's really cool to kind of see this
expanded out into the realm of Marvel
Comics and expanded to the universe but
the issue here is that Shadrach
basically says look the reason why all
of this is being done is because of what
you did to Gore the last time you guys
had not the last time you guys have
fought now again this is Jason Aaron
continuing to kind of expand on this
Jason continuing to essentially go
through and add the narrative to this
story that will increase the
relationship between gore and for
himself and the reason why is because
what Thor does in the modern
is he taiks Shadrach to omnipotence City
with the goal of basically saying look
let's see if we can't find this realm of
chronics you know basically these
time-traveling gods and let's see if we
can't figure out what in the world is
going on with them and see if there's a
way that we can basically go back and
defeat Gore or see what it was that I
did to let this circumstance in the
first place and so jumping back to the
fore in the past we end up having this
moment where during the final battle
between himself and Gore he was
effectively captured and taken prisoner
and the cool thing here is that Gore
basically you know reason wisely is
narrative is so cool is because he
starts taunting for you know now again
when it comes to course characters while
he is sadistic while he is twisted his
goal is to just kill God and so really
torturing Thor is just as much for fun
as it is for you know resulting in the
death of Thor in the first place but the
other half of this is that gorging on
simply just kill people by himself he
needs to know where they are he needs to
be able to access them and that's
basically what he's been doing going on
a mission and just traveling throughout
the universe and killing gods wherever
he finds them just happening to stumble
across them would take so long but if he
can find a God and he can torture that
God for information and then kill him
that God will lead him to other gods
which will lead him to other gods and in
turn he'll just be travelling around the
cosmos obliterating everything and
that's what he's been doing that's
really how it all started he basically
took the necro sword he became a god and
in turn began torturing other gods for
information now again for the character
of Thor the torture that comes here is
just simply for Gore to be able to
access Asgard now we know that if that
if Gore were to access as guard and try
to kill everybody likely it wouldn't
happen
Odin would probably kill him which begs
the question where zone Matt in the
future why is it that all the Asgardians
are dead again it creates kind of a
really cool narrative and it begs so
many questions and it makes things
incredibly bleak but again back in the
future with old King Thor really this is
just kind of like a continuous last
stand where he's constantly just trying
to take down these various iterations of
gore the god butchers forces constantly
trying to tear them down time and time
again at the very least trying to defeat
him and it really seems like he's
fighting a losing battle he's a one-man
army against a veritable horde of forces
coming from Gore and it really seems
like he's just going to spend eternity
fighting and basically surviving and
that's it and the reason why I say that
is because of the fact that
during this conflict he basically fights
off against a bunch of these forces he's
effectively consumed put back on his
throne only for him to continue the
pattern of trying to fight them off
again and so that's really going to be
his life
for the rest of eternity is just trying
to face off against the forces of war
and never being successful you know it's
almost like Sisyphus having to push the
rock up a mountain or whatever was you
know that mythological story where he's
constantly doomed to push the rock of
the mountain and then as soon as you
know when it seemed like he's going to
get to the top it comes tumbling back
down again so it's basically him just
kind of doomed to live out this
existence for ever and ever and ever and
so again what we end up doing is we
basically traveler I guess we follow
Gore in the modern day in his attempts
to travel into the past again this is
really what he's been doing as Thor has
been trying to track him down and what
ultimately ends up happening here is
Gore basically accesses the cronic Scott
and by virtue of spilling their own
blood he's able to use the power imbued
with them to travel back in time now the
reason for why he's doing this is to
actually travel all the way back to the
very beginnings to the formation of all
things now this is kind of an
interesting scenario because when it
comes to Marvel Comics there have been
so many different tellings of how the
universe came into existence I mean
there's the telling that was that comes
out of the classic Thor 161 and 162 I
think it is work a lot is basically
recounts his origin story to Thor
there's Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers there is Al Ewing's Ultimates
to the troubleshooter story or you
basically end up seeing the new origin
of all things in existence the origins
have been told time and time again
what's usually left to the writer is
what happens after the universe comes
into existence and that's usually what
writers end up kind of building on is
looking in this would say okay look you
know the universe came into existence
because the previous universe collapsed
in on itself it was a cosmic egg that
exploded with energy and now we have the
modern universe what happens after that
now in terms of where life comes from
this again has been explained several
times over Jonathan Hickman for example
introduced a group called the builders
and the Builder is basically just
traveled around the universe seeding
worlds and creating stars and so on and
so forth but if you go and you read some
old x-men stories odd they'll tell you
that the Celestials are the oldest
living things and the Celestials are
what they are what I basically created
the universe and then the multiverse
there's a lot of different stories that
go on here but what Jason Aaron is
saying is that in the early days
fourteen billion years ago
there were simply the Elder Gods or at
least there was the original Elder God
and this original Elder God gave birth
to other Elder Gods which in turn gave
birth to more gods which led to the
creation of planets and stars and all
that kind of good stuff
and so the goal of Gore is basically
kill this elder God steal its heart
which will ran him all the power that he
pretty much needs and then from there go
forward now the reason why he had this
rabble 14 billion years ago is because
elder gods don't exist anymore remember
we did our video series on you know the
history of the Marvel Universe the other
gods to basically wipe each other out to
the brink of extinction there was really
nothing left I mean they're they're all
virtually extinct I mean as far as I'm
aware there are no more Elder Gods not
only that it's really kind of like the
half-life concept we're just to say you
can never create anything that is equal
to yourself in some form or fashion it
will always only be a fraction of you
you know to parents for example cannot
create a child and that child has all
the traits of one parent and none of the
traits of the other it'll have a
combination of both traits with regards
to you know what goes on in Marvel
Comics it's this idea that whenever an
elder god gives birth to another elder
god that new elder god is only half of
what the original elder god could be and
so going back to the original way back
to the very first elder god is as
powerful as any elder god is ever going
to be it's basically the creator of all
things and so by stealing its heart it
basically abused God butcher Envy is
born with all the power that he will
need or at the very least it can offer a
source of all the power he'll ever need
now the other half of this is also just
pride right it's also just kind of
testing himself seeing what he can do
how far he's come and being able to kill
an elder God a being of such immense
power means that he is insanely capable
in terms of what he's able to do in
terms of how efficient he is the fact
remains here jumping into the past the
motivation for Gore doing everything
that he's done is because of the fact
that he encountered Thor and that's why
I really wanted to wait to this part of
the story to expand on this in order to
kind of you know give you guys a lot of
the information that was there and then
tie it all together and that's what
makes this so cool
with gore the god butcher his motivation
and killing gods was singular I mean he
was just a guy who was pissed and hated
gods and wanted to kill them because he
lost his fan this was convinced origin
story in ten seconds that's all he ever
did he just traveled a cosmos and killed
gods and his motivation was to just do
that he never really had a reason to
question it he never really had a reason
to believe there was anyone out there
they could challenge him
until he met Thor and then Thor forced
Gore to experience his very first defeat
and so what the law represented was the
idea that there are still gods out there
who are more powerful than Gore there
are still gods out there that Gore
simply just can't defeat because Thor
for example just has the will to win he
has a fighting experience he has the
prowess he has a strike he had the
enchanted weapons at his disposal at the
end of the day gorgeous can't beat him
through conventional means
and so what Gore began to do was
basically go around and kill all the
other gods that existed out there absorb
their power and then basically went back
killed an elder God for the purpose of
traveling into the future and securing
his reign and so that's ultimately
what's going on here it's essentially
trying to bypass Thor but that's the
idea is Authority is the source of all
this he's the reason why all this is
happening he's the reason why all this
is taking place score had been killing
gods for a while but it wasn't until
Thor arrived on the scene they goring
countered someone but he couldn't deep
through normal means and so what is up
happening here is that within the
present day with thorne arriving to this
realm of the critics cottage gods to
discover that Gore has just jumped into
the timestream and travelled into the
future
Thor immediately follows after him and
so what is up happening here is that
modern-day Thor basically ends up
travelling thousands of years into the
future with future Thor and so both
modern Thor and old King Thor are
basically fighting side-by-side in their
bid to take out the forces of for the
god butcher so what this does is it
actually ends the story on a massive
cliffhanger because the question is
asked what's going on first of all why
is it that Gore basically rules with
absolute control in the future - what
happened to earth 3 where all the
Asgardians and 4 how does it end in any
event if you guys are new here to come
us explain this you guys with the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you guys drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later please
[Music]
you